NICK CHENEY: I'm Nick Cheney.
I'm finishing my PhD in
Computational Biology
at Cornell University.
Gabriel Kreiman and I
are interested in seeing
how deep networks respond
to neuroplasticity.
So in the brain, we know
that the brain is constantly
in flux.
And neurons are
growing and dying.
Weights are changing
in response to stimuli.
But most of the time,
machine learning, what we do
is pre-train a network
on some training set.
But then we want to use it for
real-- we freeze it and keep it
in some static form.
There's been a lot more emphasis
lately on more online learning
so that you learn as you're
working on a data set.
And in those kind
of environments,
we think that the network
will be changing quite a bit.
So we're looking at
how that network could
be robust to those
kind of changes
much like the brain is
to every day stimuli
and actions it sees.
To start out just doing a
very simple test looking
at perturbations of the network.
So just throwing random changes
at the weights that make up
this network and seeing how
that affects its ability
to classify images.
After that, we're looking at how
different parts of the network
respond differently to
these kind of changes.
And then, ideally, we'd like
to have some kind of rule that
doesn't affect the performance
of the network that much
and it's able to
maintain its ability
to classify throughout
seeing a number of stimuli.
So we know that the brain
has certain learning
rules like Hebb's rule,
in which neurons that fire
one after another end up
strengthening their connections
or conversely weakening
their reactions.
Then we're soon going to see
if rules like that end up
providing stable perturbations
where the network can easily
recover and maintain
what it's doing
or unstable ones where we're
going to go down on track.
Or we know that
deep networks act
similar to how the brain works.
Jim De Carlo gave a
great talk about how
the features we see
in deep networks
are similar to the
features of the brain.
And we know that the brain
is constantly undergoing
these kind of changes.
So we're curious scientifically
to see how these computer
models respond in understanding
how these two systems are
the same or different.
But also from an
engineering context online
learning where the network is
changing while it's learning
is going to be, I think,
a much larger part
of the use of machine
learning going forward.
So understanding how
stable these things are
to constantly changing
parameters, I think,
will be quite informative
for those kind of studies.
Being able to explore
new types of materials
and learn a lot about
both computer vision
and neuroscience has
been a lot of fun.
And, certainly,
informative deep learning
is a very hot topic right now.
So being able to dive
hands in a little bit
and get some experience working
with these models and some
of the latest software
packages, I think,
will be useful
going forwards too.